На охопленому війною Донбасі є діти,
які щодня перетинають блокпости, щоб дістатися до школи.
Під обстрілами вони можуть опинитися, ідучи, так би мовити, "дорогою знань”.
Близько трьох десятків школярів із самопроголошеної ДНР
продовжують навчання на підконтрольній Україні території.
А четверо дітей навпаки  навчаються у школах
окупованих районівДонецької області.
До школи їх не завжди супроводжували батьки.
Іноді діти пробиралися уздовж мінних полів або біля позицій військових.
Інколи вони спізнювалися до зачинення блокпосту
та ночували, де доведеться.
Нині таких випадків менше, ніж на початку війни.
Утім досі ані чиновники, ані батьки дітей
не хочуть про це говорити.
Не на камеру деякі зізнаються, що й надалі відправлятимуть
своїх дітей через лінію фронту.
Школярі не хочуть втрачати зв'язок з вчителями та друзями,
а для деяких батьків щоденний перетин блокпостів -
це так само усталений спосіб життя.
Це пов’язано наразі з головним питанням сьогодення.
Батьки просто прив’язані до свого місця роботи.
Вони працювали там до війни, і там працюють зараз.
Діти, відповідно їздять з ними разом.
Ще рік тому дітей, які ходили через блокпости у школу,
було в рази більше. Коли Тетяна дізналася про це,
почала тиснути на чиновників,
змушувати їх реагувати, а батьків - замислитися про безпеку дітей.
Їй вдалося переконати батьків приблизно
двадцятьох учнів молодших класів
не відправляти дітей в школи окупованої Горлівки,
а віддати на навчання біля Бахмута.
Для цього організували шкільний автобус.
Від нас ніхто назад не повернувся.
Всі, хто прийшов, навчаються,
і бажають навчатися.Я думаю, що це головний показник.
Утім ця освіта дається дітям нелегко
Шкільним автобусом вони дістаються годинами,
доводиться наздоганяти шкільну програму за два роки,
коли вони взагалі не вчилися через постійні обстріли.
У школі сподіваються, що їм вдасться переконати
батьків щонайменше іще двох старшокласників,
які живуть неподалік, анавчаються на окупованій території.
Їм пропонують, зокрема, дистанційне навчання.
Два роки назад в нас були діти взагалі
переїхали сюди на квартиру  і вчилися
в нашій школі не дистанційно, а почали дистанційно.
Ну, захотіли.
Нині в українських школах дистанційно навчаються
близько двох з половиною тисяч дітей
з окупованого Донбасу та з прифронтових районів,
де немає шкіл поблизу. Дистанційне навчання
вдалося запровадити у 5-ти українських школах
завдяки міжнародним донорам.
Попит на нього великий. З 1 вересня школярів,
які навчатимуться дистанційно, побільшає вдвічі.